it's the israeli-palestinian conflict
getting a little dried for you dip it in
some homeless the chickpea dish is part
of a culinary battle who'd done it first
there's still a question on exactly when
and where chickpeas and tahini first got
messy so most trace it back to 13th
century Egypt but that hasn't stopped
the Greeks the Arabs and the Israelis
from laying claim and for Palestinians
the Israeli claim to homeless is the
occupation just spreading on to their
dinner plates that's taken the food
fights to the supermarket's the boycott
divestment and sanctions movement
targets Israeli made Sabra homeless for
having direct links to the Israeli
military who knew chickpeas could get so
political